well today is the last day of early
voting
and eight news now checked out two of
some of the busiest locations across the
valley ahead of the big voting day on
Tuesday November 8th Madison Kimbrough
joins us live near Centennial Center
Boulevard and Tropical Parkway now this
is traditionally the busiest day for
early voting how was it turnout today
Madison
well I went to Desert Breeze Community
Center where it was a steady stream of
people but check out this line behind me
as we are right here at Centennial
Center in the Northwest Valley people
patiently waiting making sure they get
their final vote in before November 8th
this morning I believe we were at about
163 000 who had voted in the past 13
days so as I mentioned previously
today's probably going to be the busiest
day out of all 14 days of voting It's
the final rush to early vote register
our voters Joe Gloria tells me they've
seen 3 700 voters walk in and cast their
ballot and that was just at 11 Friday
morning Centennial Center is the busiest
of the early voting locations in the
valley with lines moving at a swift Pace
while Scott and Jennifer Brown decided
to do the mail-in drop-off ballot option
well we ran out of time filling it out
and researching the candidates and so
today was the last day so we wanted to
get it in today to avoid the crowds on
Tuesday I think just that it is a very
different time and there are so many
important issues going on right now and
it just feels extra important to give my
voice and make sure I stand up for the
things that I want to see happen and the
people I believe will make that happen
and the difference this year when it
comes to mail-in ballots has far
surpassed in-person voting overall the
dynamic is changing voting in Clark
County without a doubt as a result of
mail not being sent to All voters except
for those who opted out there are
definitely more male voters who have
sent their ballots back to be processed
then all of the early voting
um in-person turnout the numbers are
higher in the mail it's over 200 000
. now people can still mail in or drop
off their ballot anytime through Tuesday
just to clarify as long as there are
lines voting will continue here tonight
the cutoff though is at 8 pm as this
location here at Centennial Center
closes again at 8 pm reporting live
Madison Kimbrough eating is now